so walk me through how you broke this  world record for running 100 miles i  really trusted myself that i was going  to be strong later in the race i feel  like there's no limits on what i can do  like if i set a goal for something like  i'm somebody that doesn't really limit  myself i'm like i just go after it i  just you know bite down and go after  that goal i feel like i'm doing what i'm  born to do as a runner i'm doing this  for the world i'm doing this to you know  elevate the sport to raise the bar and  what women  think is possible and so when i'm in  that position to you know take the bull  by the horn shoot the free throws and i  mean i just really step up my game and i  think that that's that's what i'm really  good at you know bringing bringing out  the best of me you know at those clutch  moments when you know i have that  opportunity to break a world record or  to win a world championship like that's  what i do best